كان هناك بعض الإنكار الطمع
في cpac
هذا العام جيك في مرحلة ما ،
حث المنظمون الجمهور على
تذكر ارتداء أقنعةهم
آه لأنهم فعلوا أن البعض في
الحشد أطلق صيحات الاستهجان على هؤلاء المنظمين
لمجرد محاولتهم ممارسة بعض
السلامة المرغوبة و  أعلم أن هذا قد يبدو وكأنه
محبط قليلاً ،
لكننا نؤمن أيضًا بحقوق الملكية
وهذا فندق خاص
ونؤمن بسيادة القانون ، لذلك
نحتاج إلى الامتثال لقوانين هذه
المقاطعة التي نحن فيها ولكن  فندق خاص
تمامًا مثل منزلك يجب أن يضع قواعده الخاصة ،
مدير cpac لدينا
كما ذكر دان نحن في
منشأة خاصة
ونريد أن نحترم
المراسيم التي يمتلكونها
كممتلكاتهم الخاصة ،
لذا يرجى إرضاء الجميع عندما '
إذا كنت في قاعة الرقص عندما تكون جالسًا ،
فلا يزال يتعين عليك ارتداء قناع ، لذا
إذا كان بإمكان الجميع المضي قدمًا في العمل ،
فأنا أعلم أن هذا ليس أكثر متعة
لديك
[تصفيق]
لك الحق في ضبط  القواعد
الخاصة بك في منزلك ، ونحن
نستعير منزل شخص آخر ، لذلك نحن
بحاجة إلى الامتثال لقواعدنا ،
لذا شكرًا لكم جميعًا على ارتداء الأقنعة الخاصة بكم ،
فأنا أرتدي قناعًا عندما أكون في
القاعات وسنلتزم بها  قواعدهم
شكرا لكم جميعا على مؤتمر جيد